>> MY NEW BOOK.
HAPPY JULY 4TH.
WELCOME TO FOX NEWS PRIME TIME.
>> ♪ ♪
>> I AM JESSE WATTERS.
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS THIS
WEEKEND.
MOST AMERICANS ARE CELEBRATING
FREEDOM, JOE BIDEN IS BUSINESS
CELEBRATION HIMSELF.
SPECIFICALLY THE GREAT ECONOMY
HE CLAIMS HE CREATED.
OUR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF SAID
COOKOUTS ARE 16 CENTS CHEAPER
THAN LAST YEAR.
AND THAT'S PROVE HIS ECONOMIC
PLAN IS WORKING.
BECAUSE OF JOE, BAGS OF POTATOES
CHIPS ARE 1% CHEAPER AND
LEMONADE IS DOWN 2%.
COMPARED TO A YEAR WHEN ALL OF
OUR SUPPLY CHAINS WERE STRAINED
WITH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THE WHITE HOUSE FAILED TO
MENTION EVERYTHING THAT IS MORE
EXPENSIVE.
THE BIDEN TEAM HAND PICKED A FEW
SELECTION ITEMS.
MEAT AND POULTRY AND FISH AND
EGGS AND STRAWBERRIES AND
COOKIES AND HAMBURGBER GUNS AND
POTATO SALAD ARE UP BIG.UNS AND
POTATO SALAD ARE UP BIG.BUNS AN
POTATO SALAD ARE UP BIG.
WALK OR BIKE TO THE COOK OUT
BECAUSE GAS PRICES ARE AT A 7
YEAR HIGH.
PETER DOOCY ASKED JEN PSAKI IF
THIS IS A CONCERN.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE THINK 16
CENTS OFF THE BARBECUE HAS
A BIGGER IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S LIFE
THAN THE PRICE OF GAS?
>> IF YOU DON'T LIKE HOT DOGS
YOU WON'T CARE.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS STEVE
MILLER A SPEECH WRITER TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MILLER, HOT DOGS AT A 7 YEAR
LIE.
WHY LIE ABOUT FOOD PRICES?
IT'S THE ONE THING AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW BECAUSE THEY ARE
SHOPPING.
JOE BIDEN HAS A CHEF IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT COOKS FOR HIM
AND HE DOESN'T SHOP.
>> I THINK IT UNDERSCORES HOW
OUT OF TOUCH HIGH RANKING
STAFFERS AT THE WHITE.
-- WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF AND THE
SENIOR AIDS.
POINT ABOUT GAS PRICES.
GUESS IS A DOLLAR MORENCMORENCI
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN ONE YEARS
AGO UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WILL YOU WILL AT A AN EXTRA $30
A WEEK ON GAS BUT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE HAPPY YOU WILL
SAVE 16 CENTS ON YOUR BACK CUE.
>> WHY LIE ABOUT FOOD PRICES?
EVERYTHING IS UP.
IT'S ALL UP.
>> HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU MISSPOKE.
DID YOU SAY YOU MAKE YOUR
LEMONADE BY MIXING WATER WITH
POWDER?
YOU DON'T USE LEMONS?
>> YOU THINK I SQUEEZE MY OWN
LEMONS.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE FROM
PHILADELPHIA.
THAT'S NOT LEMONADE.
>> WE USE THE POWDER.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
[LAUGHING].
GO AHEAD.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
I ALWAYS HATE GETTING IN
DISCUSSION BUSY PRICES.
-- ABOUT PRIZES.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT BARBECUE PRICES.
I THINK THE BIGGER PICTURE THAT
THEY MISSED THE BOAT ON IS THE
JOBS NUMBER CAME OUT THIS
MORNING.
WE ADDED 850,000 JOBS IN
A SINGLE MONTH.
WANGS FOR ORDINARY AMERICAN
WORKER ARE GROWING FASTER THAN
IN DECADES.GES FOR ORDINARY AME
IN DECADES.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
MADE IT ABOUT FOOD PRICES.
>> AND PRESIDENT TRUMP BUILT
A STRONG FOUNDATION FOR THIS
ECONOMY AND GOT A VACCINATION IN
THE SAME YEAR THE PANDEMIC HIT
AND IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
REBOUND.
SLASHING THE $300 EMPLOYMENT
BONUS GOT PEOPLE BACK IN THE
WORK FORCE.
>> THE NUMBER 1 FACTOR AT THE
HEART OF OUR ECONOMY'S CURRENT
ABILITY TO PRODUCE JOBS AT ALL
IS THE OPERATION WARP SPEED
VACCINE.
THAT'S THE CENTER OF EVERYTHING.
POINT 1.
SECONDLY IF BIDEN HAD GOTTEN OUT
OF THE WAY AND HAD NOT TRIGGER
INFLATION, WE WOULD BE AT 4%
UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT NOW.
NOT ALMOST 6% UNEMPLOYMENT.
FINALLY, BECAUSE OF THE
INFLATION TAKING PLACE AND THE
HEIGHT IN THE PRICE OF GASOLINE,
WHATEVER PALTRY GAINS PEOPLE SEE
IN EARNINGS IS BEING DWARFED BY
INFLATION AND THEIR LOSS OF
PURCHASING POWER.
THE PURCHASING POWER OF THE
AMERICAN CONSUMER AND THEIR
SAVINGS ARE ERODED UNDER THE
BIDEN ECONOMY.
>> YES.
LET'S GO BACK A FEW MONTHS AGO.
JOE BIDEN SAID WE MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO CELEBRATE THIS WEEKEND.
WE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO BARBECUE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT GETTING
VACCINATED.
LISTEN.
>> DO OUR PART.
IF WE DO THIS TOGETHER, BY JULY
4th THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE YOU,
YOUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS WILL BE
ABLE TO GET TOGETHER IN YOUR
BACK YARD OR YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
AND HAVE A COOK OUT AND BARBECUE
AND CELEBRATE INDEPENDENCE DAY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN LARGE EVENTS
BUT MEANS SMALL GROUPS CAN GET
TOGETHER.
>> DIDN'T HIT THE 70% NUMBER
WANT THAT'S FINE.
PEOPLE WERE BARBECUING MEMORIAL
DAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
PREDICTION THAT DID NOT ADD UP?
>> WELL, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THEY DEPLOYED THE VACCINE AND
DID BETTER THAN SLOWING THE
VIRUS THAN THEY THOUGHT WHEN
THEY MADE THAT.
68% WITH THE VACCINE AND THERE
WAS A DESCENT CHUNK OF THE
COUNTRY THAT CAUGHT THE VIRUS SO
THEY HAVE SOME IMMUNITY.
IN A LOT OF THE STATES, WE ARE
IN A GOOD SPOT.
WHEN YOU ADD 850,000 JOBS IN
A SINGLE MONTH, WHEN WAGES ARE
UP ALMOST 7% FOR THE YEAR.
FAR MORE THAN PRICES ARE UP.
IT'S NOT TRUE THAT PURCHASING
POWER IS DOWN.
IT'S UP.
IF YOU LOOK IN THE SURVEY
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED HIGH.
IT'S HIGHER THAN UNDER THE TRUMP
ECONOMY.
OPERATION WARP SPEED WAS
A BRIGHT SPOT IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND HE DESERVED
CREDIT FOR THAT OPERATION WARP
SPEED.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT CREDIT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> IT'S GOOD OF YOU TO SAY THAT.
I THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S GLOOMY SPEECH
ABOUT THE REOPENING THAT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN, HE NEVER THANKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THE VACCINE
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
THE TRAGEDY IS THAT IF JOE BIDEN
HAD JUST GOTTEN OUT OF THE WAY,
THIS ECONOMY WOULD HAVE TAKEN
OFF LIKE A ROCKETSHIP.
WE WOULD BE AT 4% UNEMPLOYMENT.
RAGES WOULD BE UP 15%.
WE ARE COMING BACK FROM
A LOCKED, FROM A PANDEMIC
BECAUSE OF THE VACCINE.
THE THREAT IN TAX HIKES AND
OPENING OUR BORDERS AND THE
SPENDING SPREE IS HOLDING BACK
OUR ECONOMY AND WORKING PEOPLE.
THE PRICE OF GASOLINE FOR
WORKING PEOPLE IS ERASING THEIR
WAGE GAINS.
THAT'S A FACT!
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO GO.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
STEVEN SAID?
[LAUGHING].
THANKS FOR COMIN